for whatever reason I learned this
because at one point I had aspirations
of maybe pursuing leadership in politics
and I learned that it was very sad to me
there was no more middle
it was there was no more moderates it
was far left or far right and it was
very hard to bring people together and
that's what really what I loved about
what you were doing and I think that
people in general especially people who
love America are looking for an
opportunity to be part of something
that's not divisive where they can love
America and they don't have to pit
themselves against other people in the
process
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast The Man Behind those custom pins
I sometimes wear including the the math
pin he's been a music impresario uh
freaking head of law enforcement an
actor you might know him as Uncle Louie
from The Goldbergs and now he's running
a thriving growth e-commerce business uh
helping people commemorate their own
service Uncle Louie himself Louis
Gregory welcome Lewis thank you for
having me man it's great to see you
we're always talking and texting now I
get to I feel like I'm visiting with you
well I feel the same way and thank you
for being such a great friend and
Champion over the last several years so
people think I've had a varied career I
mean your your career uh beats mine
solid and I have so many questions about
how the heck you you've done what you've
done so you started out uh producing rap
albums in New York City in the 80s
including some household names for
people of Our Generation well yes yes
and no I started out as a rapper I
wanted to be a rapper and uh do you want
to spit some tracks right now you mean
you have like the the gear for it yeah
man let's do it you ready yeah do it my
flow is Detra to the mental like O2 to
the lung like a crackhead be strong like
strikes to an out because it's a title
bout so let's get ready to rumble how's
that wow let's give it up now I wrote
that 30 years ago what was your rap
moniker uh I can't just I can't disclose
that I've done a really good job of
hiding any recordings of me as a rapper
you know pretty funny man it was like a
Congressional candidate in an area near
me and then his opponent Unearthed his
old rap videos as a way to attack him it
was pretty funny I mean I didn't know
what to make of it my daughters have
tried to do the same thing I've I've
prevented my daughters from finding them
so I definitely don't want the world to
find them that that's some good uh
hygiene
so you you mentioned that
you got out of the music business uh for
a particular reason like what a lot of
people obviously dream about that
business so that business has gone
through incredible Transformations most
of them negative over the last number of
years I went on an adventure after 9 11
I decided I wanted to be involved in
fighting terrorism and I started what I
thought would be an adventure and
eventually that became a career and I at
the time I left the music behind
um I remember having a conversation with
Prince Markie D from the Fat Boys may he
rest in peace and Eric B from Eric B and
Rakim and those I was very lucky to have
Legends like that as my mentors and I
said to Eric hey I'm leaving I'm going
to become a federal agent he said come
on Lou stop playing you're not going to
give up all this and go do that I said
yeah I'm going to but I never thought
you know 20 years later I would still be
wearing that uniform but 911 changed a
lot of what was is going on in the world
but as somebody who loved America it
changed a lot of what was going on in my
mind in my heart and I realized coming
from a family of people who I looked up
to that served our country that somebody
had to step up and do it and why not me
I just didn't think I was going to do it
for so long
uh being a really senior leader at
Department of Homeland Security how many
people did you manage at one point
uh well I started as a trainee as a
founding member of Homeland Security and
I was promoted nine times and eventually
I was a director working out of the
Reagan Building in Washington DC and we
had 30 000 employees
yeah that's incredible what was your
family life like during that time was
there someone who's like Hey we're
moving to DC or what was that situation
you know throughout my career we all
made a lot of sacrifice working on
holidays sometimes working doubles uh I
remember uh working with uh a co-worker
who became my best of friends his name
was George and on Christmas I would say
I'm gonna go in and I'm gonna work in
the morning so that you can open
presents because his kids at the time
were babies and he would rush rush in
like I got to get there I gotta get you
know replace Louie so he can get home
and his daughters are going to wake up
and they're going to open Christmas
presents and you have those sacrifices
that a lot of people don't realize go
into serving and then as time went on
and I traveled a lot and I lived in DC
and I spent at 1.7 months in DC without
my family so I don't know it was it
definitely takes its toll on everybody
but I think um when the person serving
is make making those sacrifices their
family is as well so you've
been of our government our bureaucracies
uh you met some awesome people and
probably some less than awesome people
uh what should the average American know
about uh what's happening in our
government that they should be excited
about and then what we could potentially
try and change
sure I I think that one of the most
amazing things to me about working
within government through the different
levels was realizing how many amazing
Innovative thinkers that we have you
know when you're pulling from a
Workforce of thirty thousand people
there's such an opportunity to interact
with a really diverse group of
individuals that all share one common
love a love of country and then when
you're working for a border security
agency and you're in a time like we're
in now and you're trying to
um utilize different types of technology
to innovate a process that essentially
hasn't changed in a hundred years right
somebody comes on a boat or an aircraft
they present a document they wait in
line and we all dread waiting in any
kind of line and we have to figure out
how do we bridge the gap of Technology
enforcement and make that more of an
enhanced experience for everybody and
when I was in headquarters I worked with
a gentleman who was considered the
father of global entry and he did just
that he created this trusted traveler
program because we always were of the
thought process that 99 of the people
coming are good law-abiding citizens
yeah so why make them go through this
huge uh process when we could
essentially screen them in advance and
it's like pushing the Border out so his
name was John Wagner and he created
Global Entry which was Not only was it
an amazing program for people who travel
but it saved the government a lot of
money because we spent less time doing
things that didn't need to be done it
was very efficient and it created from
as far as I'm concerned one of the
largest surpluses of income for the
government because as you know people
are paying for this membership it's like
any any entrepreneur would love a
subscription based program where people
are paying money for something that's
intangible and then renewing it
frequently and who is your your base of
customers every single U.S citizen in in
our country so that's a great
opportunity right to to bring income in
and then you say okay well what you know
what are we doing with that income now
to put it to work for us to continue
down that path and I think there's still
huge opportunities in that area well
you're clearly a Serial entrepreneur
you're running a business now that you
started you've started uh in like
totally different Industries uh you
mentioned the border and I'm sure most
people listening to this are very
discouraged by the political
conversation around the Border where
most Americans are generally on board
with uh the fact that we need to have
borders and and have them be secure and
then treat people who are trying to get
in
um humanely but enforce uh the rules as
as they are
um the problem I think most of us kind
of sense is that it's a bit of a mess
where rules aren't actually being
enforced in any uniform way and I was
reading about how
the Border uh forces have a really hard
time getting and keeping people because
apparently it's just a miserable
miserable job they're not well
compensated they're down in relatively
desolate uh abandoned areas so I was
reading like the average stint of
someone on border duty is something like
18 months like as soon as someone gets
there they're like I gotta get out of
here and and so then we're having these
political conversations like oh we
should do this we should do that
meanwhile uh on the ground whatever
policy you're designing you're not
necessarily going to be able to enforce
right well it's certainly not a
glamorous job for the people on the
Southwest border and recruitment is
always very difficult and I think for a
lot of people they may not realize what
they're signing up for and it's it in
today's society it is a thankless job
and it's a very dangerous job so when
you sign up for a job where you're
essentially in in the desert trying to
prevent people from entering illegally
in between ports of Entry and you know
there's things that you may not think
about like where do you go to the
bathroom and this is particularly a
difficult situation for I call I don't
call it but border patrol calls it the
five percent they have only five percent
representation of female border patrol
agents because it's not the job doesn't
lend itself to the the simplest of tasks
like how do you go to the bathroom if
you're in the desert right so when you
get this job and they're recruiting they
show you these high-speed videos
helicopters boats Vehicles rushing
through the dunes but they don't show
you like you know the the day-to-day bad
stuff that you have to do when your
office is the real grand and you're in
Del Rio and you're trying to figure out
like okay what what's next it's it's a
dangerous place to be so I I've I've
never heard the statistic of 18 months I
personally think it's a great career for
people and it does have a lot of
opportunity to earn to have benefits and
to have a great retirement but it
certainly doesn't go without the dangers
of law enforcement and literally the
Wild West
I've always been a mattress guy it's one
reason I'm so thrilled that this podcast
is sponsored by Helix sleep Helix sleep
is the future of mattresses you take the
Helix sleep quiz at their website and
get your perfect mattress fit in under
two minutes it takes a little longer for
them to get that to your door but when
they send it to your door you get a
hundred night free trial I know it's
crazy that's over three months and then
over a 10-year warranty to try out your
new Helix mattress it's become the go-to
mattress for my kids in the house and
they have a few mattresses to choose
from but they just always seem to find
this one you don't need to take my kids
word for it it's also the number one
mattress pick by wired GQ imagine that
job just trying out mattresses for
magazines but it's number one and it's
number one for a reason Helix is
offering up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com yang
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
starts now
[Music]
so how many years were you in the
federal government 20 years
oh my gosh that's incredible holy cow
man and when when you've been in the
government that long don't you get all
these crazy sweet benefits packages and
everything else like uh why do I feel
like you're departing the government was
somehow an unusual decision and also how
the heck did you wind up on ABC's sitcom
during this time where I know you're a
psych after member and the rest of it
well when I started working for the
government I remember meeting the
old-timers and they were on a different
retirement system it was called csrs and
I was on First and essentially at some
point in time the government decided
that the retirement system was too good
so they ended it and I was on the new
one which wasn't too good so it went on
a formula based on your high three years
and then it's such a bad retirement that
they allow you to they call it Bridge
your social security so you're retiring
at an age where you can't collect your
Social Security yet but they're
acknowledging that you couldn't survive
on your retirement alone so they allow
value to collect that Social Security
early if that makes sense so it's not
the most lucrative of of retirements and
for me I took a deferred retirement so I
don't collect my retirement because when
I decided to take that leap the leap of
faith to give up a paycheck every two
weeks to Chase my dream of being an
entrepreneur I didn't know if it was
going to work so I wanted to leave that
door open so that if I decided you know
in the next five years man I made a
really big mistake I want to go back
uh that was that was this the decision
bib the decision that I made you your
retirement is augmented by your ability
to save along the way in what they call
the Thrift Savings Plan which is like a
401k for government employees so you can
pull in a new annuity on top of your
retirement and your Social Security
stipend
um but the average person working on a
border SEC on a border for a border
security agency whether it's border
patrol field operations or air Marine
they're making 120 to 160 000 a year so
if they're managing their money properly
and they're saving like their
taught to save in their Thrift Savings
Plan they should be doing pretty well
for themselves so so you made the
decision the decision to become an
entrepreneur uh and you started an
awesome business that people can check
out I think the website is Uncle
louis.com no actually
um the website is americasfrontline.com
and the uncle Louis website Uncle Louie
redirects that's what happened yeah yeah
so and and that's kind of related to
what you mentioned about uh how I
started acting I when I was a kid I did
theater and I always loved acting and
music and
um I loved the show The Goldbergs
because it took place in the 80s which
is my favorite time 80s toys 80s music
um
yeah so um the creator of the show who
it's based on Adam Goldberg had reached
out to me many times
and he was like hey do you know this
person can you help me
um to bring this 80 star on the show and
we did so much together like the 80s
hookup I was the 80s hookup I was the
80s hookup and then eventually he's like
you know you really need to be on the
show and I was like I really want to be
on the show because it's my daughter's
favorite show and how cool would it be
we watch it together every week if I
don't tell her and one week we're
watching and I come on the show so it
evolved into that
um I did you know some episodes of that
show and it was an amazing experience
Adam became a friend
um and it wasn't until I actually went
to New York City I think in 2019 and I
sat down with Michael Strahan who's
become a Monumental figure in my life as
a mentor he's just taught me so much
he's a great guy super great guy and he
said to me you know everything you're
doing is so cool the UFC the WWE
um acting music uh Homeland Security but
have you ever thought that if you stop
doing all that and just focused on one
thing how great you might be
and that was a tough pill for me to
swallow because I really did I loved all
of those things but he was right
and I came home trying to wrap my head
around why I needed to focus on just one
thing and what would that one thing be
right would the one thing be wrestling
WWE because I was working with Bill
Goldberg at the time or would it be
music is this like some kind of like
Goldberg mind meld like everyone who's
well you want to know a funny Goldberg
Side Story
um Goldberg called me one day Bill
Goldberg from WWE and he was very upset
I can't believe they made a TV show with
my name and I didn't approve this how
does this happen and I said well bill
there's other Goldbergs out there you
know and this one happens to be a really
nice guy who by the way grew up
idolizing you right because he was named
Adam Goldberg and he loved Bill Goldberg
and he's been trying to get your uh TV
agent to get you on the show but they
keep saying you won't do it I think it
would be a great idea for you to come on
the show and an opportunity for you to
show that you're great comedic actor oh
I don't know I said well if I can get
you a deal if I can negotiate a deal
where you have multiple appearances in a
recurring co-star will you do it yeah
I'll do it but it's got to be it's got
to make sense so I went back to Adam and
we did it and Bill became the gym
teacher so we got Goldberg on the
Goldbergs and you know uh I think
shortly after that uh bill got cast for
NCIS and he's been doing a lot of TV so
everything tends to come together and
happen as it should but because of
Michael Strahan's advice I focus just on
uh my company which essentially creates
first responder-centric artwork and
turns it into Collectibles whether it's
coins pins patches I'm I'm wearing a new
pin that I made for you the unveiling of
it not left not right forward thank you
sir
which is something that you've been a
huge supporter of
um from the the get-go
foreign
if you know me you know that I think
that our data should be ours and that
big Tech right now is running roughshod
on our autonomy our agency our privacy
for sure one way to help turn the tables
on big Tech is to use expressvpn like I
do when I surf the web it keeps you
private by piping you in to another IP
address it's what big companies use it
was rated the number one VPN that's
virtual private Network by CNET wired
and more let's take it back from Big
Tech Stop handing over your personal
data to the quasi-monopolies that mine
our activity and sell our info for their
profit not ours protect yourself with a
VPN I trust to keep me and mine safe
online visit expressvpn.com Yang that's
expresvpn.com to get three extra months
free
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
foreign
now when I was running for president I
had perhaps a dozen maybe more maybe a
couple dozen military
veterans or current enlisted uh come up
to me sometimes also First Responders
and then say thank you for what you're
doing and then give me a challenge coin
and urging me to keep going and it was
always immensely meaningful because it
made me feel like they understood the
spirit of service that animated me uh
and it made me feel like I was an
honorary part of a Brotherhood and I
feel like that's what your company does
for more and more people it enables them
to feel also like they're supporting
some of the people that put their lives
on the line to keep us safe whether it's
at home or abroad I appreciate that
um I look at my my coins as artwork and
as you know the first amendment gives us
the right to express ourselves right
wrong or indifferent and I think that in
history three there's been so many times
throughout the history of the world that
artwork has been censored and when I
create something I try not to put a spin
on it I try to sometimes capture a
moment in time to capture an agency or
on the mission of a particular event and
then I hope that what I create does
exactly what you said that it makes
people think that it makes them feel a
part of something and that it starts a
conversation and a lot of times I will
create something because something has
happened in the world and I feel like
either the media is putting a spin on it
in a certain direction or it's important
and nobody's uh thinking about it and I
want to make sure that it becomes a
tangible thing so to see so many
thousands of people collect them and to
get a feeling you know to to be able to
create something that gives anybody
anybody any kind of feeling is powerful
yeah I mentioned to you before we
started recording that I was in South
Carolina
and literally 65 percent of the forward
party leaders and members were either
military veterans currently in service
or from a military family and it really
made me feel great honestly I was like
oh these are the people for is
attracting like we're doing something
right uh why do you think it is that
folks who have
committed so much uh like you have
frankly are attracted to forward
you know I was talking to Christopher
Vaccaro who's working on my book with me
that you had recently spoken to and
we've spoken to such a diverse group of
people and whenever we bring up politics
they it tends to be so divisive right uh
it's either so far left or so far right
and I think that people in general
especially people who love America are
looking for an opportunity to be part of
something that's not divisive where they
can love America and they don't have to
pit themselves against other people in
the process right like if I go back to
before I really knew what a Republican
or a Democrat was
it didn't matter to me what I didn't
know what a political affiliation was I
just knew that I loved my country and I
knew that my parents loved our country
and as I got older and as I worked on
the border I gravitated towards the
right because the the right were
supporting the mission that I was on to
protect the Border and then
as I got older than that I realized that
everybody wants to protect the Border
it's just being politicized and it
shouldn't be politicized because
politics are not part of keeping America
safe our mission in border security is
to facilitate lawful travel and trade
right so one of our biggest missions
after 9 11 became anti-terrorism but
what people don't realize is one of our
biggest missions in protecting the
borders to facilitate facilitate trade
right so we have an economy that is run
by the Import and Export of goods and if
that cargo cannot come in and out safely
and if the United States cannot ensure
that the products are safe for Commerce
and they're not going to hurt children
they're not going to have chemicals that
create an issue for people or animals or
introduce pests into uh you know our
Citrus Farms it's such a dive diverse
Mission but nothing in that mission has
anything to do with politics
there's a universal desire for Public
Safety which isn't
um isn't political it's not ideological
right and yet unfortunately in our
current time uh 99 of things in American
Life become a political football where
it's either you know like this or that
so you've personally trained probably
thousands of law enforcement officers
that the country recently has been
racked by this video of uh black man
Tyree Nichols being killed by police
officers it was a ghastly horrifying
video one of the things that did make me
grateful was that these cops were
charged with murder and arrested
themselves which is something that you
know you rewind 10 12 years ago I mean
that used to be what the protests were
about which was like the cops aren't
being brought to Justice
um
do you have any thoughts on uh the
training of law school Enforcement
Officers what's our way out of this like
you know like you see something terrible
like that and what goes through your
mind
I I see a lot of missed opportunities
and
um I believe that Congress is in a
position to affect a lot of change that
can correct so much of this but I don't
think they're focused on the problem
um and I think the problem is twofold
one part of the problem we and we can
discuss both one of them is training and
the other one is equipment so the first
thing that I think needs to happen is
that all law enforcement agencies use a
use of force continuum and use of force
policy dictates that you use the least
amount of force to control the situation
to bring a subject into compliance or to
make sure that people aren't hurt and
once that happens you de-escalate and in
the situation that you referred to the
de-escalation it didn't seem to happen
so that that's problem number one and
that leads me to a training deficiency
and I think back about
my training and the training that I I
can only draw from my experiences of
what I've been through as far as as
training and I have asked friends hey
when you train or you ever put in a
scenario where typically in in your
training you have two officers and a
non-compliant subject one is the cover
one is the contact the contact officer
speaks the other officer provides cover
there you could because you can't have
two people talking at the same time
so is there a training being done that
teaches Law Enforcement Officers what to
do when their partner or somebody in
that altercation doesn't do what they're
supposed to do do you how do you divert
your attention from the subject to your
partner like hey this is not okay you
need to stop right ask tell make so if
they don't stop you need to make them
stop but if you're not training people
how to do this you can't expect them to
do this and that needs to be drilled
into all law enforcement officers from
day one you do what you're trained
that's that's your you're programmed to
conduct yourself by how you train to
so if we're not training them how to
respond in this situation then
leadership is just as much to blame as
the officers that are
committing these crimes and when I look
at Congress I've met with so many
um representatives from the house and
I feel like they they have an
opportunity to divert resources and
funding to creating
um a standard right why should every
Police Department have a different
policy why should every Police
Department have a different use of force
does it make sense that the use of force
in California should be different than
the use of force in Seattle or New York
or anywhere else
right we're all humans we're all in the
United States of America it should be a
uniform use of force and I think um in
addition to that we need to be
um researching the police weapons and
the police uniforms to put them in in
two scenarios one a uniform that's going
to better protect them and two some sort
of
intermediate Force weapons that the
weapon of choice is not going to
necessarily kill somebody but can still
have the same speed of stopping them and
I'm not a scientist I'm not an engineer
but I think if we can send people to
outer space and we can outfit people in
things that can protect them at the
highest of altitudes and land on
different planet right if we can land on
the moon we can certainly give the
police officers an opportunity to even
if they gain four more seconds in their
thought process right so if I when I'm
talking to you right now on this video
stream
there's no delay right you can hear me
right away
right so if I I'm going to ask you a
question and I want you to answer it
what are you going to give your family
for dinner tonight
uh Shake Shack
so I think that that took you four or
five seconds to figure out okay so part
of our training is that we have to in
our weapons qualification we have to
come from our holster
a more weapon in and fire three rounds
in three seconds
that means within three seconds I've not
only determined that I have to kill you
I've done it
so how can I make that determination
when you can't even tell me what you're
going to have for dinner in the same
amount of time right but that's the
training that we're giving and how do we
change that we change that by figuring
out a way to buy more time because
ultimately that decision is sometimes
between the decision between life or
death for that officer so they're
trained that they're going to go home at
the end of the day so what can we do to
outfit them better so they have two more
seconds because sometimes that two more
seconds right can show you that when
somebody's reaching this is what they're
getting
right but you you you're it's drilled
into your mind right three seconds from
The holster and that's just not enough
time so if we can send
I've lost track of how much money we've
sent to Ukraine but what I haven't lost
track of is how much money we've spent
researching how to better outfit our
police how to create uniform training
for them
because none no resources from the
Congress have been given to that so
since the terrible incident with George
Floyd
the Howie police hasn't changed it's the
same so if we want to change that we
have to look at our training and we have
to look at our equipment and we have to
be able to bridge that Gap and innovate
in the same way we innovate how we
create systems and processes we have to
innovate how we police and how we use
Force well one thing I have noticed uh
in the headlines is that it's harder to
recruit police officers in various
locations and that that's a long-term
negative for everyone in my opinion
because you want good cops but there are
a lot of places where uh citizens just
want more of a police presence because
of uh insecurity or public safety issues
and the rest of it and if you can't get
people into service in that way
uh I mean I met young men who and women
but I'm thinking of a young man
um who talked about how being a police
officer was his dream job and then now
he's not so sure and that just really
made me sad you know because he was a
good kid and I sense that he would be
the kind of cop that you'd want out
there we need more cops like that yeah
yeah we just need like in you know but
if if we create an environment where uh
being a law enforcement officer is
something that everyone avoids uh then I
mean then we're we're screwed because
you know like you're going to have
Community suffer as a result right when
you were running for president one of
the things on your platform was to
legalize marijuana at a federal level
and that to me is so important for
America on so many different aspects but
believe it or not I feel that that's
part of the problem
one of the problems with recruitment for
police because we want to have community
policing right we want to have people
from a community policing that Community
because they understand the cultures
they they know the people but so much
culture in America so many people grow
up around things that are
deemed to be
for instance marijuana is legal on a
state level
it's illegal on a federal level so what
that means is if you grew up in a place
where that was part of your culture and
you were around it chances are when you
take a polygraph to become law
enforcement you're going to fail the
polygraph so now we've just taken those
people out of the equation they cannot
become police officers and to me that's
a that's a big problem right because
we're we're essentially on a state level
saying okay no problem this is legal all
right but I know it's legal but since
you did it you can't be a cop right well
that's the kind of thing that you would
realize and think about that the rest of
us wouldn't but it makes sense uh and
certainly I think most people watching
this would agree that if you grew up in
an environment where they were spoken on
some weed uh that shouldn't preclude you
from being a cop I mean heck to your
point it might even make you the kind of
cop we need
someone who's who's going to be focused
on the things that the community is
actually worried about we should all
have discretion we should all know that
anything that you do if you do too much
of it it's a bad thing
um and if you are a human being and you
make mistakes it should not mean that
for the rest of your life you're Pro
precluded from being part of
the solution that's that's you know the
a big aspect of this and also I think
that when the government gets together
and creates a baseline for use of force
and says we're gonna make this Universal
they should also create a grant program
where people in these communities that
have policing problems have a path to
becoming a police officer where they can
go and the government will say x amount
of dollars is going to be given in
Grants for you know folks from these
areas to become police officers because
that's part of I'm into that man
absolutely if we need it I mean there's
a recruitment problem and uh if we can
give people a pathway to becoming an
officer and solve the the recruitment
problem I mean that's a win-win one of
one of the biggest things that was taken
out of 9 11 which led to the creation of
Homeland Security was that there's too
many stove pipes too many different
agencies unable to communicate so they
wanted to level the playing field and
bring everybody in line with each other
so they could work together and make
sure there was open communication and
these things would never happen again
the same thing should apply to how we
police America we should not be policing
on different frequencies
well you talked about George Floyd I
mean there was a massive
a burst of energy for reform and nothing
passed at a federal level because of our
political polarization you know you're
essentially like 50 50 and so what it
does is it highlights the need to reform
the system in my mind because a majority
of Americans are for some type of Reform
they're also for uh
a lot of other things uh you know around
uh reasonable Common Sense uh firearm uh
guidelines and rules uh addressing
climate change I mean there are a lot of
things that most Americans are for that
you just look up and be like well can't
have it because system and and that's
you know that's you know and it's it's
making people nuts because you know
that's not the way we're brought up to
think our country functions like we're
right up to think hey enough of us want
something it's a democracy and we should
be able to get it but instead it's like
oh nope can't have it uh the the you
know like it's not going to get through
Congress and and that that's the hard
work that we're doing at forward thank
you for for being a part of it so right
now you you have an attachment to
Florida and Florida is at something of a
unique juncture politically uh and I
think that your community is somewhere
kind of purplish uh in the middle what's
the the vibe in Florida yeah Florida is
um it's got pockets of different
components of political affiliations and
for whatever reason I learned this
because at one point I had aspirations
of maybe pursuing leadership in politics
and I learned that it was very sad to me
there was no more middle
it was there was no more moderates it
was far left or far right and it was
very hard to bring people together and
that's what really what I loved about
what you were doing
um and I see local politicians where I
am um there's one her name's Robin
bartleman and I really try to get behind
some of the things that she's doing
because some of them for our community
are good and then I see
um she voted against stricter penalties
for trafficking Fentanyl and I'm like
how could you not you know do everything
you can because I was killing people
yeah it's killing people if you're
trafficking I mean right and that's
that's another example of something
that's been politicized fentanyl is bad
it doesn't matter if you're a republican
a Democrat an independent it doesn't
matter what planet you are on fentanyl
is bad so if people trafficking in
fentanyl there was a bill introduced
that said hey you know this could be
considered
um attempted murder if you sell this and
I said well that's a great idea because
we need to make the people are going to
die yeah trafficking this understand
we're all a million in the next 10 years
I think something like a million people
will die from Fentanyl so why don't we
take a stance why should that be
political why should we allow
politicians to dictate how we protect
our children we're all having I hope
we're all having conversations with our
kids like hey don't take anything
because it may not be what what it's
purported to be it might be Fentanyl and
it might kill you yeah it's tragic
what's happening to so many families uh
you know and teenagers are buying one
thing and is laced with fentanyl and
then and then they they overdose and die
uh I it was just reading about how
there's an effort now to put Narcan in
more schools because some kid might just
end up overdosing and teachers want to
be able to bring them back and what I
thought was well it's a good idea we
should do that because it might save a
life here and there but what have we
come to as a country where the freaking
teachers and principals are thinking hey
like is there a Narcan in the building
right and to make matters worse a lot
out of these precursor chemicals are
being imported into the United States
right and many of those chemicals are
not on the DEA schedule yet some of them
are some of them aren't
but people are importing them and
they're making these things themselves
and you can go on to Amazon right now
and you can order a pill press
don't you think that's something that
should be regulated
right oh yeah man why the hell do you
need a pill press unless it's for
something these are the questions that I
feel like Congress
is not asking like Congress is like this
is bad China's sending this into our
country they're trying to destroy us and
then it's like okay but you're going to
give them the combine pill press you can
buy the machine
why aren't you taking the steps to
I mean in the very least if you're going
to buy a pill press there should be some
sort of a need and and it's just like
guns right they say well I use the I use
this gun for hunting okay I use this
pill press what do you use the pill
press for what's the reasonable yeah
what are you making at home
we got to know where that's heading but
have you ever heard that question asked
I have not until now you know uh I've
learned a ton from you I learned a ton
from you every time we we talk because
you you have such a deep background in
things that most of us don't think about
because you spend years trying to keep
us safe and if we wind up in position to
be able to influence policy brother
you're gonna be one of the first people
I call and we can pick that uh brilliant
mind of yours for problems that we can
solve if people want to support you your
business uh what is the best website you
are on social media but what is the what
is your business's website the website
is America's Frontline line.com and I'm
in the final stages Chris Vaccaro and I
are finishing America's front line which
is a book uh an autobiographical
leadership book of my story uh a little
kid who wanted to be a rapper who became
a director with the largest law
enforcement agency in America and then
left it all behind to be an entrepreneur
so hopefully man we have to
have you back when the book comes out
especially because I think I make an
appearance you're a super Patriot a
Serial entrepreneur and a great man a
great friend Louis Gregory Uncle Louie
has given up americasfrontline.com
seriously man when does the book come
out
um the book is in the final stages
um Chris is wrapping it up now and I
think probably in about six months it'll
be out but I will text you and I would
love to come back and share it with you
six months it's a date I'll brandish
that book and I can't wait to read it
thank you my friend thank you for having
me